I did I feel a [ __ ] stupid saying
this I'm doing this new acting class I'm
not gonna [ __ ] yea bore you guys with
the stories from this [ __ ] but I I guess
gotta I gotta tell you about this this
one thing the first thing that happened
yesterday a very first thing get to this
class okay
this is recording right oh yes okay that
freak me I can see the light yeah yeah
you so first thing you get to this class
so it's like I don't know 12 people or
something in the class and the very
first thing we do is an exercise okay
and this basically did she's teachers
big on like marking yourself so figuring
out like what what you can get cast as
right doing that like really focusing on
that okay cuz that'll take you to
wherever else you want to go right
apparently Brad Pitt got big cuz he
looked like a cowboy so we're just doing
Cowboys [ __ ] forever and then you got so
big that it was like alright you can do
whatever you want now alright so that's
the thing right so the exercise was you
[ __ ] introduce yourselves to the
class and then you sit down so you say
hey what's up you look everyone and you
sit down facing the other way
okay and they have to they have to just
yell all the things that they their
first impressions and you write
everything down okay
okay so it's basically like it's
basically like what you could play like
how they see you like anything but car
mechanic you can be a good cop right
right I see you as like a 70s rocker
chick you're like a groupie like that
sort of [ __ ] right so into it like four
people and every single person before me
it's like it's like yeah she was like a
like a intelligent sort of like business
ciggies exact like a woman in charge
right oh you're like a great like a like
a young mom like the fantastic professor
that's how I see you a computer hacker
whatever I go up hey guys Cody I'm Cody
nice to meet you I sit down very first
one influencer and I'm sitting there
like are you [ __ ] kidding me I got to
change my whole life you say that's the
thing I'm a method actor
I've been method acting as an influencer
for about five years now everyone thinks
that I'm sort of an internet funny guy
and they just don't understand it's one
big experiment so I'm really glad to
hear
you say that yeah no honestly you nailed
it that's exactly what I wanted you to
say
yeah no I'm going for it yeah actually
yeah I've covered the puppets puppeteer
baby clearly I've watched the just
something special the way I'm speaking
later okay here let me read can I read
the rest of the yeah go for it
this is that this is the real [ __ ]
list okay influencer BAM house DJ nice
specifically car influencer [ __ ]
literally said that says dude and bro a
lot haha
Matt just start up okay bully in high
school okay beer pong nice gym teacher
likeable douche sells coke in the
bathroom that was the last one and
they're like great thanks and I'm like
I'm they just burst into [ __ ]
Eddie you roasted me dude and they're
like clapping they're like good job
don't [ __ ] clapping me you just you
just destroyed my self-esteem for like
10 solid minutes now I gotta go sit down
and be happy with this whole [ __ ] I got
to change my whole look now I got to
sell all my clothes yeah you can say
goodbye to the [ __ ] knees
yeah there's no mercy my knees for the
last time no more I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna go to Banana Republic
yeah cut my hair short business cash I'm
going business casual now and I want I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be like a smart
bartender or something nice yeah with
the [ __ ] you should get some shavoo
hair product while you're at it - I want
to go in there Jay I want to go in there
just for that part and then when they
get done I will just want to start
crying like like hard like like a start
weeping and then just like oh yeah
cry-baby yeah yeah yeah great cry-baby
you could be a little snitch just keep
crying and crying beat them out until
they like don't get this the exercise
anymore and and then when I get them all
and they start consoling me I can just
stand up and go [ __ ] prank dude
pranked
who's the influencer now [ __ ] yeah I
don't need this farmer right here
there's a camera right yeah look right
to the teacher I don't need this [ __ ]
class
I just got an A
later peace homie I just can't believe
influencers the first amaze yeah
brutal that's such has become everything
I've hated there's that but also I'm
gonna give I'm gonna give you like a
little bit of a little bit of benefited
death of the doubt yeah what do you gas
me up a little bit I'll guess you have a
look ask me have a little bit and give
you a little octane right here I think
on one hand yeah maybe they're right but
also I actors don't always strike me as
the most up-to-date on just pop-culture
current events you ever talk to an actor
and they're just grossly like out of
touch your experience that I mean yeah
so what I'm saying is I think they're
coming from a place where you remind
them of someone on their facebook mm-hmm
you know I'm saying yeah Oh Susie I'm a
facebook influencer know what I seem
better know what I'm saying is what
they're pulling from is their local
experience mm-hmm yeah oh yeah yeah
you're a dude likes beer pong yeah oh
man a guy with blonde yeah
a guy with long hair dude you're totally
a beer pong guy [ __ ] what cuz I
got okay yeah sure you know what I'm
saying kind of yeah they it's it's I
can't it but it's also like it's a
little bit like sobering cuz it's like
no that's you nailed it you did
what do you mean influencer yeah as much
as we [ __ ] we are as much as we hate
to say it [ __ ] are yeah what so what
does hell's coke in the bathroom I sell
coke in the bathroom sometimes getting I
don't but I just say dude I do say bro a
lot I do play beer pong yeah they nailed
it it's just like a sobering look at
yourself you're like damn is this what I
look like yeah this is why I look like I
want to go in there and just say
horrible [ __ ] mmm some guys in Santa
Rosa computer hacker pedophile rapist
whoa oh definitely date rapes yeah
definitely you [ __ ] poison chicks dude
for sure you got kind of like a Bill
Cosby vibe you be the next Bill Cosby
for sure I'm like shut up man it's you
all you see that I am white I'm so
creepy super creep you like a gross
disgusting [ __ ] creep you [ __ ]
weirdo gross that you get
oh oh oh um um this guy upskirt videos
on the subway
that's this guy yeah oh you're like a
[ __ ] gross little peeping tom
definitely dude definitely oh my god oh
it's coming to me
um southern belle no no incest monster
yeah yeah dude that's that's you girl
you [ __ ] your dad yeah yeah right oh
yeah oh oh oh oh cam girl sure but not
like a good one I broke one you know I'm
saying like no one likes to see you on
your cam dude your cam sucks like max
three gamers always yeah failed cam girl
for sure oh my god homeless it's
definitely homeless you can are you
homeless you could easily be homeless
just rude [ __ ] um definitely background
dude just only background yeah yeah you
should insane extra yo a little harsh
back there oh my god uh definitely a
person that should lose weight I can't
believe they say that about you Cody I
can't believe they get you like that
that was the last one yeah definitely
should lose weight oh yeah definitely
like you should you could play a guy
that's like going on a diet or like
definitely just weird nice roast um do
with bad ankles yeah like kind of like
fat ankles
yeah dude with kind of fat ankles that's
you man you definitely fall down a lot
in the script yes should be your thing
yeah that's basically what it was that's
what the exercise was this roastin was
cut it was a little bit I felt like a
little bit I felt weird did anyone else
as bad as you not really that was the
thing well so you got it the worst
I definitely got it the worse not a flex